je ne sais pas en tout cas si les
fondateurs de la société image à
angoulême ont moins de 30 ans mais
toujours est il qu'ils auraient
certainement pu postuler pour le prix de
la fondation douce la société image va
fabriquer des machines assez original il
s'agit de vidéos poste interactif ces
vidéos postes permettront la recherche
sélective d'information en images
nicolas jacobs a pu voir le prototype de
cette machine qui a même déjà son mode
d'emploi
regardez
pour les jeux de l'e3 uniquement et
marche fort vous avez le choix
vous venez de vous asseoir face à une
banque d'image son coeur le voilà c'est
un vidéo disent qu'il contient 50 mille
images 35 minutes d'animation
mais sur ce disque que tout ne vous
intéresse pas vous cherchez un
renseignement précis et c'est là tout
l'intérêt du vidéo poste interactif en
dialoguant avec vous il va vous aider à
trouver ce que vous cherchez un spot de
publicité par exemple ici l'univers
images
peinture bande dessinée anime aussi posé
des lampions
ici univers de l'animation graphique
nouvelles images vidéo art dessin animé
vous avez le choix
sorbet aux fruits
non c'était pas le glas et mousse glacée
enfouis ils ont tenté le vidéo poste
interactif devrait intéresser les
centres de documentation mais aussi les
entreprises qui ont à présenter au
public leurs produits ou leurs services
les agences de voyage par exemple qui
pourront ainsi présenter en images leurs
clients toutes les destinations
possibles
les débouchés sont importants
potentiellement en europe et aux états
unis il existe déjà depuis quelques
années en europe
l'accueil réservé par nos prospects ou
nos clients potentiels aux produits
concrétise nos ambitions dans ce domaine
on peut dire que vous êtes une société
de très hautes technologies une société
de très haute technologie
c'est l'un des aspects et deuxièmement
on est confronté à un surf permanence
sur les innovations technologiques et
sur les contraintes du marché vidéo
place tel qu'il est va être miniaturisé
va voir s'adjoindre des possibilités de
télécommunications de paiement
électronique
c'est ce qui conditionne le profil des
gens travaillant dans une société comme
la nôtre qui doit créer du matériel et
aussi les programmes et les services
adaptés aux différents secteurs
d'activités aux technologies nous en
resterons là chez image on reste très
discret sur les techniques mises en
oeuvre en particulier sur l'élément
principal le système informatique qui
pilote le vidéo disque la production
doit commencer cet été l'entreprise
emploiera environ 12 personnes à la fin
de l'année une cinquantaine fin 85